hello and welcome to round four here at the tata
steel chess tournament it is early in charlotte
dania how is that coffee well it's early for chess
players i realized to my [ __ ] that's actually
tea i've uh traded in but i've resigned the game
um made some loose leaf tea but uh you know the
games never failed to wake me up it's like the
strongest cup of coffee anywhere all i need is
a couple of night orbs fiona all i need is uh
round four of tata steel if only around four had
just begun oh wait a minute it has i can't wait to
jump into the action fiona thank you everybody for
joining i am super excited for another day packed
with fun matchups and fun action absolutely let's
hope the players are in a fighting mood today
and let's remind everyone already tomorrow is
a rest day so often the players you know they
give it their all tomorrow they can rest all
they want but before we go to the games let's have
a very quick look at the results from yesterday
so yesterday we had two decisive uh results the
first decisive game of the day was hari krishna
taking down the leader niels grandelius and then
the second one was actually the last game of the
day to finish kept us here till late at night
ali rizza fuja playing a positional masterpiece
uh to beat the winner of last
year's challengers group david anton
indeed and yesterday was equally defined by
the non-decisive matchups of course arientari
drawing uh his compatriot one magnus
carlson relatively unknown player
um that was a big result for aryan particularly
with the black pieces drawing an end game where
you know magnus was renowned for his ability
to squeeze those end games and uh really the
heartbreaker uh fabi playing a an absolutely
spectacular tactical game against jan shistop duda
uh really just a phenomenal calculation
throughout the whole game but young's just
uh incredible calculation to save the game in
time pressure fabi was winning at one point
didn't drive it all the way home all of them are
going all of these players are going to be hungry
uh to continue their good play this
round yeah and with uh fabiano and
magnus failing to capitalize on those white
pieces that means that we now have a big tie
in the lead of the tournament let's
bring up the pairing so a five-way tie
at the top with harry krishna magnus carlsen anish
kiwi fabiano caruana and niels grandelius on two
out of three indeed it is a log jam at the top
and uh definitely the leaders will be defined
at the end of this round coming into rest day
number one i'm pretty sure that we'll see a
more well-defined group of leaders and um we've
got some mouth-watering matchups today fiona
absolutely let's bring up our
favorites the boxing like head-to-head
even there you can always like feel some
of them look friendly others look like yeah
i'm gonna crush yourself oh yeah i'm coming
to this tournament i'm scoring some points
but i think they're all thinking that but
they're all going to score some points there are
they all already have everyone's already have yeah
i mean i we said it yesterday i think it's really
great to have nobody on zero out of three um
because we've mentioned it so many times and here
well the last match-up of the day probably
the main one and here we have the pairings
one more time giving us a bit more time to uh
to discuss them the last one there was jordan
van ferece the local the local hero uh taking
on magnus carlsen what is really intimidating
it's like particularly intimidating he really
does yeah i mean jordan i don't think jordan
is going to be looking at that that boxing video
before the round i think he's jumping he's more
intimidated by magnus's opening repertoire but
jordan has shown his ability time and time again
to compete on equal terms with the top of the
top yeah he's so far undefeated uh this year and
today with with the white pieces i think he'll be
look well we'll get to the games in a second but i
i expect jordan to be looking at to be looking for
a fight today against the world champion what else
do we have one match-up is between two players
from our leaders group it's pantala hari krishna
against fabiano carrana how do you think fabiano
is going to feel after the missed opportunity
from yesterday fabi is a very objective player
i think he you know he doesn't really tilt that
easily um and that's one thing that's always
impressed uh impressed me about him is the fact
that he you know he can have a disappointing
result and then come in the next game and
and make a very solid draw and harry kreshna is
playing with the white pieces so papi is going to
play for a win he's going to use his chances
but he's not going to play you know e4b5 or
he's not going to go crazy he's going to play
what he would play win lose or draw in the
previous round well shall we uh we can discuss
the the remaining pairings as we get to the game
shall we see actually maybe start with fabiano
c and confirm that he hasn't opened with one b5
yeah well he i believe has played b5 yeah he
has but it wasn't on move one it was a move
five actually uh it was a rylo lopez which you
know really needs no introduction nor explanation
um actually would you agree we have seen very
few have we even seen a single ray lopez yes
i mean i i'm trying to scratch my memory i
mean i really don't don't remember a single
one i think we haven't had a single one that's
actually quite that's actually quite crazy i mean
it's it's such a common opening have we even had
we didn't have a berlin that's crazy i mean you
can remember how many berlins you would have like
even a year or two ago i think there has been this
we just had very few e45s we had a one italian
we had one petrov but very literally 45 action
yeah that is just quite crazy i mean yeah wow
but anyways we did have a uh a rye lopez here
and um uh fabio responding would be with the
i believe this is called this is actually
embarrassing i think this is the archangel bishop
c5 i just know this is the bishop c5 variation and
uh you know people who know their lopez would know
that bishop b7 is the sort of traditional mainline
and um after rookie one b5 bishop b3 black can
play d6 or black can play the marshall attack
which was castle c3 d5 that's a gambit uh but
not to delve too deeply into these sidelines
bishop c5 is a very popular sideline among all
levels and hari grisham responding with a4 very
typical move opening up the queen side and then
occupying the center and now just move a5 and
and after a5 the whole idea is that you know black
takes on eight pilots to the knights then this e5
pawn and that's the classic rye lopez upon the c5
is going to fall so that pawn on a5 i believe is
basically untouchable fabi drops his bishop back
hari krishna stops fabi from developing his bishop
to g4 and so papi says all right i'll be in keto
i still think this is well within uh the range
of theory i'm quite sure this has arisen many
many times fiona uh really the accident is yet
to come here but bishop c5 usually an indicator
that black you know wants some active play and uh
is uh looking for for a very fighting game
here today yeah no absolutely and and uh you
know this line bishop c5 is it's not the kind
of line you place it's not like the berlin
there's no force draw against it and you
play it if you want a good combative game
it is dangerous in the sense that it requires
knowledge of a lot of theory um but fabi is very
well known for his incredible opening preparation
and has been known for that for many years
yeah actually speaking of uh well he's been
working for a number of years with rustam
kansemjanov and i actually just saw rustam for the
first time here today in vik just 10 minutes ago
because today it is the day before the rest day
so it's the day where everyone has to uh to go for
their second covet tests and i think uh i think
fabiano had said on the opening you know muslim
on principle one come to the playing
hall he'll just you know stay in the room
uh in these covert times but today he made he made
a rare appearance here uh the the track down well
i have a joke i have an early morning joke for
you fiona uh what did cousin jonno help fabie do
um after fabi didn't play chess right
here shake off the roost the rooster
maybe we could work on delivery yeah no i mean it
was so funny that i needed to like understand it
because i knew people would basically die laughing
but it's something at least i mean it's 8 13 a.m
who can really make jokes at 8 13 a.m but anyways
back to the position what is white's main move
here um i'm pretty sure that rustam among
others have helped fabiano prepare in this
position i believe that black white needs
to decide where to put this bishop on c1
uh one square is of course g5 that really
needs no explanation you're pinning the knight
and often what you see in these positions i've
seen this a million times is as black tries
to excommunicate the bishop and of course the
sacrifice on g5 needs to be very well evaluated
because you know the queen's going to come out
to f3 this is a super sharp position i i actually
still think this is probably theory uh and this
has occurred and the other way of developing is
bishop b3 and you might look at this and say
wait a second you're just blundering upon but
no if you take a look at this knight it's being
x-rayed by white's rope and with this move g5
white basically wins a piece after bishop takes
you through rook takes e3 both knights both nights
are hanging and you can't move one night and the
best you can do is give up one of the knights for
a pawn but that is of course not satisfactory
compensation fiona so i think these two moves
among others and bishop degree has just been
played bishop e3 has been played and fabi well
five actually if we look at his clock times uh
he's currently been blitzing out uh all his moves
up two minutes from the starting time and
let's see if bishop e3 comes as a surprise here
uh it seems to be going for his first little thing
of of the game but sometimes the players are of
course just trying to remember the different lines
yeah i mean believe it or not the top players are
humans and it's not a great sign and i've shared
a couple stories from my game with fabi at the
2017 u.s championship but another one is that
i i played the french with black i don't know
what i was thinking i played the french i really
don't know what i was thinking against baby of
all people he of course goes for the main line
and i have done some good preparation before the
tournaments and uh i mixed up the move order of
one of the main lines and it wasn't the sort of
mix up that's forgivable i mean i'm basically
losing out of the opening and the moment i mix
up the move order bobby starts to think and
i'm like oh no that means thinking that means
i mean i've done something that's not theoretical
that means i'm probably losing and i won't i mean
yesterday uh it's funny what he was saying reminds
me a little bit of yesterday what we talked about
this insane game between uh fabiano and young
christophe duda and i have to say it was really uh
so brave by duda you know he said he knew if he
entered if he played the petrov he was probably
entering fabiano as a world championship match
crap but he said you know i was just too curious
and wanted to see what he had in store there
which is incredibly brave yeah sometimes you you
just want to test yours man this is such a solid
opening what is it that my opponent can do to me
but anyways here's the fascinating thing fiona
we have three rye lopez's and i mentioned them
if we can quickly go to mbl against anton and we
will of course check into magnus and the other
interesting matchups but just very quickly we we
do actually have a marshall in the game between
mbl and davidonson and the marshall is this move
d5 i just mentioned that while talking about hari
hari's game and i didn't know that david anton
had played it this is a gambit and it is a gamba
that is named after american player frank james
marshall who was a very very interesting very
combative chess player i believe he played
this against uh former well world champion
jose capoblanca uh the cuban genius and i actually
think marshall actually lost the first game but um
he nonetheless did some analysis in this line and
the name bears the line bears his name so black
sacrifices the pawn actually maybe let me ask you
a question because i've never played the martial
from either side and my understanding and just
watching these games from afar was always that
if both players know the world at the line
super well that it often leads to a forced
draw how correct is that that assessment
i think that's pretty correct i think
uh if you check correspondence chess and we see
very typical moves being played here this is
a little bit odd that move rookie four for example
but it's actually quite normal i mean the the rook
coming to h4 is quite normal trying to smoke that
queen out of h3 and i think by and large fiona
your assessment is correct i think a lot of top
games do end in draws because you know this has
been first of all so exhaustively analyzed that
um if you mentioned this in the 1970s people would
look at you and say what do you mean marshall
dry it's very combative but now you know black's
activity usually counterbalances white's extra
pawn i've had the marshall several times from both
sides i played it once with black drop uh ding
liran played it against me with black and you know
i was quite happy that he did because i knew one
of the the drawing lines that i managed to make a
draw in a pro chessley game and i think i faced it
one more time that was also a draw it's just very
very very exhaustively analyzed and white keeps
coming up with new ideas black keeps analyzing
them and it always uh peters out somehow into a
draw but we will see if mbl has any new analysis
uh this move d3 by the way for those interested
in how the theory has developed d4 has always been
the main line but uh i would say about 10 15 years
ago players started realizing that the move d3
has its merits because this keeps the e4 square
defended and and that might not seem significant
but if you imagine later in the game a night
appearing on e4 or even a rook appearing on e4
uh that could be potentially important fiona so
we will see how this plays out absolutely and
interesting shaping up to be an interesting game
shouldn't we check in with uh with magnus carlsen
on the black side against europe magazine i think
too weak i don't think he deserves to commentate
his game uh sure absolutely and another lopez
amazing they're making up for the making up for
the what's the the word something with d yeah
is there a word like a derf yeah yeah that's a
good word dearth of jerusalem the pasity of ray
lopez is that's another good word the pulsar is
best said in a british accent the positive roy
lopez is in this tournament is quite appalling
actually speaking of uh of british accents uh in
uh in not too long from now about 40 minutes from
now we'll have our first guest and it will be uh
doctor and grandmaster john nunn so maybe he can
maybe he can pronounce that for us yeah certainly
wouldn't presume to draw even the british accent
that's incredible what's a guess yeah john none is
absolute legend we'll we'll talk more about him uh
soon we will have another legendary guest coming
later but we'll keep that a surprise for now let's
take a look at what uh variation of the rylopez9
displayed and magnus playing yet another uh sort
of i think this is called the molar this should be
seven so we have seen two ways to develop the dark
squidward right uh davina and zone developing into
e7 and uh fabi developing it to c5 magnus develops
the other bishop first and this line is sort of
related to the main lines and it's important to
recognize that knight g5 may come to mind wait
a minute isn't this winning nope uh black can
play much like he does in the pride liberty 5
he takes d5 and i believe either even 94 or 95
and uh the thing is black roots out this bishop
and that's no good for light once the rye lopez
bishop disappears white's play really doesn't
uh doesn't go anywhere and and so this has been
proven to be fine for black jordan instead
focusing on developing his pieces knight c3
a3 to create an escape square for his bishop in
the event of knight a5 but magnus going knight
t4 sticking the knight in the center offering up
a bomb uh jordan could have accepted it but then
after knight takes b3 takes something like d5 kind
of like the marshall fiona what that gets all this
counter play and white's pawn structure is ruined
so jordan instead taking the knight and we have
this very interesting position on the board what
are your thoughts about what's transpiring so far
i think it's uh interesting that magnus is
choosing as somewhat off the beaten uh track
uh line here against jordan's ray lopez jordan
who's very well prepared i think it it makes
sense to to take an approach where um you know
you don't go for some absolute uh main lines to
test your opponent but rather try to to get an
off the beaten track position where magnus can
try and outplay uh jordan you know in the
middle game no definitely the the molar is
far from being the main line it's you know it's
reputable it's not one of those crazy sidelines
but but it definitely is a sideline without
a doubt it's off the beaten path in the sense
that bishop b7 is quite a bit more theoretical
and i think jordan jordan's moved d3 is also not
quite the most i don't want to say combative
i think it's probably just as good as the main
lines but i believe usually in the rylopas when
you're playing the main lines you play like c3d4
that seems to be the most topical and um jordan
has shown that positionally and and you know in
these complex middle games i was also impressed
with this game yesterday against voitisha uh
which a game that kind of flew under the
radar but but hey you know jordan had
maybe a slightly worse middle game roddick is an
incredibly strong positional player and he drew
the game from a position of strength i
mean he played a flawless positional game
yeah an impressive start from jordan who is still
unbeaten in this uh this year's tata steel and
certainly shaping up to be an interesting
game this one absolutely so maybe i can run
through some of the key ideas as i see it in the
middle game now now what we need to notice here
is the fact that the center is kind of unbalanced
and that just visually is it is apparent and you
know black's pawns on c5 and d4 do look imposing
and black can contribute to his central control by
playing a timely d5 so i think jordan has to deal
with that and he also has to deal with this knight
on e2 that knight is currently not very employed
so one idea that comes to mind is knight to f4
just centralizing the knight and if uh magnus
plays d5 and jordan could meet that with e5 and
the knight is pressuring but i don't like this
move as much because it it blocks the development
of the bishop we've talked about the dangers
of that so the move i like more is knight to g3
that is a very typical idea in the rye lopez old
as the hills that knight potentially can access
the f5 square and if magnus playing d5 here which
he very well might then i still think jordan could
respond with e5 let's say knight d7 and he could
support this pawn with f4 the one concerning thing
fiona i think is after c4 bishop a2 this bishop is
definitely out of the game for the time being but
yeah that doesn't mean it's permanently we can
go to b1 and later that diagonal can be opened
that does make sense i'm a little bit
so if if with this idea that you're
just showing if the bishop goes back to to
b1 and then we play c3 do we not have to
be concerned now there's no way black can just
entomb the bishop i guess well black can trade
this and then you know the thing is white actually
and i know this is the weird thing to say white
doesn't always need all of his pieces to really
generate attacking chances so something like f5
here and you can see him queen g4982 white's got a
lot of pieces that are in the game and they can be
enough to overpower uh black's king side because
black's very well protected i love the look on
those pawns on e5 and f5 yeah very appealing yeah
yeah i mean this is dangerous so black can't fall
asleep on on the king side just because the bishop
is sort of bad for the time being yeah i mean it's
a super rich position and then be interesting
to see which which approach the players decide
like to go for absolutely you know jordan can
also perhaps develop his bishop to g5 that's
certainly a viable alternative and we will monitor
how he solves this opening problem but shall we
have a look at some of the other games yeah
let's maybe go to alireza furuja who played
such a brilliant game yesterday and today he's
up against another youngsters both of them are of
iranian descent ali ruiz are currently playing for
defeated flag while arientari was born in norway
of course and always has represented norway
absolutely and alireza choosing once again
one of his favorite recent openings the karo
khan and uh we see the advanced car with e5
and uh the bishop ii variation i think this has
happened once before did uh magnus in his own game
anyways i played this as black i said against
magnus um right i think it was i maybe somebody
could remind us but i'm pretty sure i've seen this
once before this tournament in inaudible's game
uh i mean which is not surprising because this
line with bishop p2 is considered to be one of the
most testing uh and popular systems against the
kernel actually i think it was definitely against
what was it against mvl ah
it might have yes i think
you know this is very well studied and i think
aryan choosing a bit of a different system
than mbl i think mvl kind of oriented himself
toward playing c4 at some point where astari says
all right i'm going to defend the pawn on deep
i'm going to build up the pawn chain much like
you do kind of in the advanced french and then he
plays his move 91. now this moon 91 is i've seen
this idea before that knight is three shuffling to
d3 and why is this maneuver necessarily there's a
couple of things if the knight gets to d3 first of
all it's going to discourage black from playing c5
black can certainly play c5 now and uh that
does come with its attendant dangers you know it
weakens this diagonal and you know even g4 needs
to be considered here at some point that bishop on
f5 could get in trouble in certain positions and
sometimes this trade is actually very beneficial
for white i can then run his f-pawn straight down
the middle and uh it can be very hard to stop this
idea i actually think g4 is is a very legitimate
threat a positional threat in this position so
alireza has to come up with something against that
and the other thing is that you know once that
knight moves away sometimes this bishop opens up
and you discourage black from sometimes playing h5
you sometimes see this move uh actually h5 may be
interesting here to stop g4 and if you take on h5
and i think queen h4 is going to create
very very nasty threats down the h-file so
we'll see how alireza responds to this
but 91 is well within the bounds of
normality yeah i'm curious curious to see what he
does h5 certainly looks like an interesting and
interesting option but ali raza he mentioned in an
interview that day against after the draw against
danville you know he loves the carican so we'll
see we'll see what he comes up with we certainly
will and uh as ali reza ponders his next move
let's have a look at some of the games that we
have not seen uh we have a couple of
night orbs actually side by side here
uh any preference and or should we
have a look at doodah geary maybe first
okay let's start with dudagiri and then we'll then
we'll get to the the knight or the knight orbs
yeah and this one is jose gruenfeld and and it has
the signature bishop on g7 you can just tell open
center fiance bishop and one d4 a combination of
those things because gruenfeld and it was indeed
a grunfeld but mvl is really known as the top
group specialist giri of course also an opening
expert so this isn't a surprise choice from him
and we see here the main line this is one of the
most popular variations of the greenfield one of
the oldest lines as well and this move b6 i am not
myself a grunfeld specialist full disclosure what
i do know is that the old school main line used to
be take stakes in bishop g4 which is very logical
you're indirectly applying pressure on the g4 upon
you're inducing this weakening move by three now
black counter attacks white bishop with night a5
that used to be all the rage but recently oh
well relatively recently people have started
to play b6 and essentially you just sacrifice
the pawn but and you do that in order to ruin
white's pawn structure to activate the bishop
and uh in order to also get this e5 square
for black's knight which geary immediately
occupies i have seen this entire line before
and i'm quite sure the black equalizes here
with best play but you have to remember a lot
and if you get one thing wrong with black
you can end up down upon for no compensation
i always find this so dangerous to go for these
you know exercises and memorization to go for a
line that you're like okay i have to be confident
i remember every single detail of this variation
and one wrong you know one wrong step and i'm
just a pawn down and i'm i'm seriously worried
so but anisha me i mean nanish is
known for um for knowing his openings
very well so i'm confident but still a risky risky
approach oh absolutely and and as we mentioned
these players sometimes they do confuse
lines it doesn't happen very often because
the amount of time that they just spent rehearsing
their files reviewing their analyses but it does
happen and uh what also should be mentioned
is that white has it's not that white has one
line that you can go into white has seven or eight
different attempts all of which are quite testing
and black has to know all of them you have no
idea which one your opponent is going to choose
so actually well speaking of options what are
what are our options here uh as white our knight
is hit and this central square is looking
like the most natural i guess yeah knight d4
looks natural but the issue here might be
the smoke queen c7 i'm not entirely sure
uh but this creates of course this
pressure on the c3 pawn and after bishop v4
i'm thinking that black can take a sort of tame
approach and just develop this bishop to b7
uh this move a5 is very tempting you might try
to go after the c3 on the issue here might be
the counter-attacking move knight to p5 hitting
the queen and defending c3 i'm sure this is also
not that bad for black in fact uh jan kristoff has
decided to drop back to a3 yeah so he's decided to
leave the d4 square for the bishop which makes
sense because that square is a very very good
one the bishop is centralized and it will protect
c3 and the knight yes knights on the rim are dim
but uh that's not entirely true because that
knight can go back to c4 and try to dislodge its
its vis-a-vis on e5 so due to definitely trying
to consolidate here you said that black has a very
narrow path having to remind remember all the
lines here what is the idea for black is the
idea to try and get the pawn back as quickly as
possible or just go for active play and get the
pawn back in the longer longer term i think it's
the latter i think it's it's to go for active
play and get the fine i mean you wouldn't mind to
get the pond back you would accept it if offered
it's like you know i've eaten dinner but if
somebody offered me a burger i probably wouldn't
refuse it but i think you know queen c7 to that
end is is sensible here if white plays bishop e3
okay sure i'll take the pawn white white's not
gonna do that white's gonna go bishop d4 but by
and large i i think fiona yes the idea is to go
for activity which would be seven and then maybe
put the rooks on on d8 and see it activate all
the pieces and uh hope for full compensation for
the pawn maybe rook t at first i'm not entirely
sure uh this also makes makes a lot of sense
let's uh let's come back to this one let's see
those two night orbs we have uh we have today
uh let's do it so first we have we have a dungeon
co against erratic voice check who is a perennial
nadar player and a very interesting position that
we have on the board let's see how this happened
h3 h3s8 by alexander h3 of course i think this
is sometimes known as the bobby fischer variation
and it has been one of the most
if not the most popular line
i would say in the past five years too on a white
intense to expand on the king's head with the muji
and would you say this is the sharpest try against
the night or it is certainly i mean i think bishop
g5 remains extremely dynamic instead of h3 but
it definitely leads to very very sharp positions
especially the line that roddick chooses e5
and h5 which which may seem quite radical
uh if that makes any sense but it
is actually i think the most popular
it is actually the most popular response
against this line because black simply stops g4
this idea of playing juport is so annoying that it
is worth creating this weakness on the king side
to prevent uh to prevent this
move from happening and uh we see
white instead playing g3 and kettling the
bishop this is all very normal knight c5
centralizing tonight getting an outpost and rook
a7 another i would say a relatively typical night
of idea which which may seem weird but you are
preparing to deploy the bishop to b7 i'm curious
because sorry you said that until now everything
sort of was very standard but if we look at the
clock times radic has already spent 25 minutes
so what was the move do you think that came came
as a surprise to him yeah my guess is maybe 95
because the way that i've often seen this done
is i often see a4 played first and after b4
then you go knight t5 but maybe in alexander's
preparation you realize that the inclusion of
these two moves somehow favors black and one
way that that might be possible is that as we
see rook a7 bishop e3 chasing the rook to b7
and g4 anyway sacrificing upon in order to open
oh actually that's not even a sacrifice because
if you attempt to simply take the pawn
myopically then queen 6b7 will win the rook
so that rook is quite awkward and alexander can
deploy his knight with knight 395. maybe the
inclusion of a4 in some lines favors black and
that might be what uh radek is wrestling with
and such a sharp such a sharp position and i mean
definitely a good sign for uh for alexander that
he has somewhere managed to to catch radoslav
uh off off guard i mean it's always so nice when
you play a game and you manage to catch uh your
opening your opponent somewhere and somewhere
you surprise them and you get this immediate you
know half hour up on the clock but what are what
are black's uh blank options here after g4 yeah
i just love looking a little bit concerned um
well the zero v7 is what bothers me he's actually
just gone h4 uh so i'm there on camera yep so he's
trying to prevent this knight from activating
via g3 and uh what is alexander going to do i
mean if this is still his preparation then i'm
pretty sure he definitely factored this move
factor this move in to his preparation it does
make sense and i think that the key question for
white is which side is the castle and i wouldn't
rule out either queenside or kingside gas because
one argument is that you want to castle queenside
so that you can open up the king's side with that
four but the thing is if you cast a king
side that doesn't rule out the movement
four in fact it can make f4 even stronger for
example let's say black castle we play a four
after e takes up or knight takes up board that
rook is already poised to wreak havoc along the
f-file and uh yes it is through the white's king
is a little bit weaker here so you have to weigh
the pros and cons do a cost-benefit analysis
i think we're going to see alexander either
castle on one of the sides or maybe play out four
immediately but this is very very sharp indeed
and this is one of the games today that uh
we're certainly gonna keep coming back to
shaping up to be a very very exciting dual shall
we see the other the other night or that we had
indeed we shall as pango against nils
grundelius as nils attempting to bounce
back after that painful loss yesterday against
hari hari krishna and here we have a more tame
uh night or the bishop is considered to be by
many the relatively the quietest line against
the matter because white uh intends only to castle
king side and that doesn't mean it's quiet in the
grand scheme of things it's still a night or if
it's still very very full of life but it was a
favorite of anatoly karpov and after e5 knight b3
bishop v6 here's a very interesting thing fiona
um this move bishop e6 as far as i remember it's
always been considered an inaccuracy uh due to
f4 and queen c7 g4 has been the main line since
like the 70s but i think niels has analyzed this
position in all of the books you will find that
bishop e7 first is always the recommended move
bishop b6 is never recommended but that's the
fascinating thing about openings in the recent
recent day and age a lot of these things are being
redefined reconsidered computers are breathing new
life into lines that were always considered bad
before and i mean it's also the beauty of having
players like niels in this tournament you
mentioned you know he's such a creative
player but i i'm struggling to understand
still i mean i i'm not a night of player
and i think it's so tough to to understand the
different nuances and the little details as to
what difference does it make especially here
i guess that white united white didn't go
e4 f4 um can you explain or sure what
difference could it possibly make yeah and
maybe somebody all right show me your id
what makes you qualified to explain that
well i did play the night or my whole life
basically until i was around 25 50. so
i'm certainly nowhere near the level of expertise
of some but i'll attempt to maybe explain some
of the key here so i think what the what the
game revolves around is sort of the key factor
is this pawn on f4 and what happens to it and
one of the reasons that uh the development of the
bishop to e6 is frequently discouraged is because
white can play the move f5 with tempo why is the
move f5 particularly good well the problem is it
attacks the bishop right now let's say we just
take the knight if you notice this d5 squared that
square is really really weak and you can imagine a
reality in where in which you know white can put
a bishop on c4 he can put a piece on d5 and then
he can start attacking on the king side with for
example rook left a lot of games have been lost
because black doesn't really have any counter play
you can just see how passive black's position can
be if he can't break through with the move t5
so that's i think one of the key reasons that
this is often delayed and what is niels possibly
thinking here one of the things that black has
started doing in response to the move f5 is this
move bishop d7 the bishop is redeployed to c6 and
basically black tries to break through with d5 if
black is successful in breaking through with d5
then white's position can also collapse very very
quickly here so i think that that's going to be
the key if white doesn't play f5 then black does
sometimes take on f4 and then use that e5 square
as a base of operation for for his knight so one
very typical idea is to play e takes f4 and then
knight c6 95 and that knight on e5 is the pride
of black's position so several factors here that
might define uh the next couple of moves if huber
i'll put you on the spot if you were right here
what's your initial instinct what would you go for
i i would probably go for f5 i mean and this might
be like a duda syndrome where i'm very curious
what exactly niels has prepared um but you know f5
is definitely the principal move but my secondary
candidate would be queenie one queen c3 which you
know which is a queen lift up to g3 in order to
put pressure both along the g pile and on the e5
so well this is another game where yasipanko has
taken a lot of time compared to compared to his
opponent he doesn't seem like he's ready to make
a decision just yet but certainly another game
um which is shaping i think today we're spoiled
once again oh yeah absolutely some very combative
lines you're absolutely right isabenko taking uh
quite quite a lot of time here which which makes
sense because you you know puns don't go backwards
if you play with like f5 and then you allow black
to break through with g5 why did i play at five
then you play if you play queen e1 and maybe
black takes on it ah why didn't they play f5 so
it's one of those things i explained yesterday
you are going to regret whatever decision you make
uh and you know that too that's the worst thing so
you keep trying to weigh pros and cons you can't
decide if it happens he's actually he was actually
looking if you look at him on camera there i know
you have a couple of seconds delayed it looked
like he was actually regretting his choice already
even before making it and then he played queen d3
okay so that's actually a similar move to queenie
one i i do think that he is thinking about putting
the queen on g3 that's just a you know he's taking
the 485 rather than 77. he's taking one freeway
rather than another sorry not everybody will get
their reference those are charlotte freeways yeah
oh my god you haven't heard of the freeways
in charlotte unacceptable um i don't know if
i would even manage to place charlotte on the map
actually yeah i mean i wouldn't have either before
i moved there so i still might not not be able to
in any case um queen d3 and what is the benefit of
putting the queen on d3 versus e1 because queenie
one queen truth oops sorry i did not mean to
click to the and i i think we may
need to uh refresh one moment here um
so let's see if uh if i can get this to work now
so basically oh uh just one moment my apologies
yeah actually maybe um maybe we're
gonna go on a very very quick uh break
uh in order to bring the board back so we'll
be back in just just a second don't go anywhere
and we're back with all the action from uh
round four and let's just jump straight back
into it you're just gonna explain to us the
differences of the queen going to d3 or to e1
yeah i mean i think the queen is is
you know there might be no difference
it might transpose but ultimately the queen is
is supervising uh the center i i brought up this
story of uh you know sometimes when you're in
time pressure and you need to go to the bathroom
in an over the board chess game you do
this weird little dance where you're
you're getting up and you're looking back at the
board and you make sure you take the path to the
bathroom where you can see the board all the way
to the bathroom so that if your opponent makes
a move you can run back to the board and make a
response and this can be thought of in that way
the queen is sort of supervising the center making
sure that a move like d5 something crazy like this
is out of the question because here
after f takes e5 at the very least
uh and that's probably not even the best move
but that certainly does does the job i mean now
you just take on e4 and you're up upon if you had
played queen e1 then i actually do think that d5
uh would have would have been a legitimate
candidate move maybe not a very good one but
something that would have needed to be reckoned
with because after f65 knight takes c4 uh you know
black restores material equality and you get kind
of an unclear position so that might be one reason
um perhaps there's others as well in case white
plays f5 the queen does keep the d5 square under
supervision so uh it seems quite quite a subtle
idea but it's a big i kind of like this move
that's certainly a metaphor i won't be forgetting
the queen being linked to a player trying to get
a bathroom back a break while long time but let me
keep d5 under control yeah anyways sorry that's a
little out there but hopefully it helps people see
understand the position better that's ultimately
the goal i'm sure it will i'm sure it will um
well magnum not magnus niels is still considering
his options but shall we go back to to magnus's
game yeah definitely lots of stuff has happened
in that game we had observed the moment after c5
and jordan deciding to develop his bishop first
which is sensible we had talked also about knight
g3 and we will see that move played in just a
second after d5 we have a mass trade first jordan
takes the knight on f6 to soften up the d5 square
oh and we are back that was quick apologies about
that but we are straight back with the magnus
game um and yeah the piece is coming off the
board yeah and i think what i was explaining
is that this e4 square can be covered by a pawn
that lands on f5 so one idea is to play bishop e5
and if you just sort of play knight e4 and say
well look at my knight my knight is awesome
no it's not get out of there f5 and that knight
is chased away so that actually can get very
dangerous for white if jordan doesn't find a way
to kind of establish his pieces in the center
his position can get very cramped and uh to that
effect i think magnus can can play bishop b5 he
doesn't have to rush with that that would be
a very magnus-like decision just very calmly
waiting for jordan to play 94 and then playing
the 55 but in the events of something like this
then jordan could go queen f3 for example and
uh control that square and perhaps also then
threatening this knight f6 check x-ray so this is
an important decision for magnus and you're going
to have a very classic battle between knight
and bishop which piece is going to be stronger
i like magnus's position here i think he's got a
little more space he's got a good pawn structure
but i really i think the position is equal and
i think jordan is doing a good job of uh really
sort of you know getting kind of composition where
uh magnus could start getting frustrated that he
doesn't have quite the kind of winning chances
that he might like to have yeah i'm curious uh
curious to see where the piece is and what
do you think is the ideal piece placement for
for both sides here yeah i mean the real question
is does you know when does dwight want to play an
84 because you don't want to rush this move as i
as i explained another idea is to play the move
g6 or maybe the bishop should be being carried
and and tucked away safely and another idea of
course is 94 bishop and once again black is ready
to play f5 now and chase away the knight so jordan
doesn't want to rush with that uh so maybe you
want to keep the knight on g3 for the time being
another key question is do we want the queens
off the board if you're jordan if you're magnus i
don't think it's worth going queen f3 and ruining
your pawn structure in order to trade queens but
you know that that's not out of the question
uh because there's really nothing to exploit
this pawn structure with black is slightly better
here but it might not be enough to win the game so
and the third question is does magnus want
to play the move c4 at some point and expand
his queen side on pressure that move doesn't
really accomplish anything in and of itself but
maybe it's part of a series of moves that puts
pressure on white's position very interesting
position uh it may look very simple but there's
a lot of decisions to be made for both both sides
here i mean certainly far from simple in general
but especially not when you're playing against
magnus and magnus who was left you know slightly
frustrated yesterday i think after his game
against zaria and tyree where uh a lot of pieces
came off the board early uh early on and although
magnus was pushing ever so slightly it just
wasn't enough and magnus has indeed gone uh c4 so
he has decided to expand that pressure on the
queen side and put some heat on white's d3 pawn
now jordan certainly does not want to take this
pawn because that would uh that would move that
key uh defender from the e4 square it wouldn't it
would deprive the knight of its natural placement
jordan has a couple of moves here queen
g4 comes to mind just activating the queen
of course that old move knight e4 we talked about
should certainly be considered and maybe jordan
wants to play something like rookie one sort of
procrastinating uh in a good way improving a piece
and seeing how magus just decides to arrange his
pieces i have a question if we go queen g1 are we
kind of threatening to play knight h5 oh
yeah i think we definitely are uh just
for example let's say black improves the
position of his rook we can go in at h5
and uh well this threatens knight takes f6 because
of the pin and efficient p5 i think you intended
to move f4 and that's definitely quite unpleasant
for black black and saved the bishop by playing
f5 and then dropping the bishop back to upstate
so that the rook protects that bishop but this is
definitely probably going to bail out and that's
not what magnus wants so certainly that's that's
an idea actually if the bishop and the knight
were to to come off the board do you think magnus
would still have a little something as his pawns
are more advanced or do you think it would just be
even that's a good question i'm not entirely sure
i think magnus maybe has a tiny something so for
example queen g3 bishop has to drop back and see
if i were jordan i wouldn't take on f6 here that
bishop isn't going anywhere i would play the
move rook at e1 and try to wrest control of the
e file from from white one of the common mistakes
that's often committed in these kinds of positions
is you just assume ah to draw what you want and
then what happens is black will play rook after
e6 he's like no no no i'm not giving you the
e-file and now you can't play rookie one and now
ideas like queenie two or queen e3 check
become very very unpleasant so these games
that seem very drawish are often lost
because one side loses control of a key file
yeah this already i wouldn't wanna i wouldn't
wanna be white here but yeah certainly uh a lot of
things to to consider here for you and i
like your suggestion though of queen g4
because i also feel it's about time i linked
linked my works um and and got the queen out
i'm actually i'm struggling to even think
of of other moves right now yeah i mean
queen g4 certainly is supernatural um well
not supernatural in the sense of ghostly
uh or magical but it is it is very or extremely
natural uh but rookie one i think is is also
a sensible move and 94 should also be considered
uh but i i do i am leaning toward queen g4
the one problem that i will mention and this is a
little bit maybe i'm going a little too deep but
if black does play this move g6 that i had
mentioned and then drops his bishop back to g7 one
problem is that this queen on g4 could actually
get caught in the crosshairs of this move f5 that
move could come with tempo and you certainly don't
want magnus to gain all control of the e4 squad
with tempo so maybe that is something jordan has
to factor in i don't think it's a deal breaker
per se but it is it is a factor that you know that
jordan should definitely consider while making his
decision and he's taking his time here this is a
complicated moment for sure absolutely let's leave
jordan to it for now we'll come back to it uh can
we check in what was that that um lidor was it
the grandest game or um well grandelias is well
there's it's a penguin delias and uh cepanko is
these are our two our two darlings our two night
off games let's check in on the other one don't go
against voice check this is definitely a sharper
night off and we joined uh we had seen this moment
right when roddick had gone page four and uh
responds by donating a very very sharp f4 uh just
trying to open up that f-file and the one thing
that we mentioned is he's got to decide where
to put his king and for the time being keeps his
king in the center uh which is which is sensible
but i think at some point and perhaps that moment
has arrived he has to decide which way he castles
my inclination i don't actually know i mean
castling is short i really like the fact
that this gains control of the file but certainly
a big decision here to be made by alexander
yeah a lot to consider he also he spent 20
minutes since we last left him just on that
one move f4 and now considering his next option
uh so we will leave him to it as well we're
actually going to take just a very very short
break to set up our first guest of the day i'm
very much looking forward to having doctor and
grandmaster john nunn with us in just a second so
don't go anywhere and we'll be right back with him
welcome back and i'm absolutely delighted
to be joined by a very special guest
grandmaster and dr john nunn uh john
welcome to the show it's an absolute
pleasure having you well thanks very much fiona
it's nice to be joining your show this afternoon
maybe just a quick introduction uh seeing as you
know there's been so many new people coming to the
game uh this year who might not be familiar
with all the all the things you achieved in
chess and in uh in numerous other fields so john
is a three-time world champion in chess problem
solving we'll talk about that in a sec he's a
very prolific chess writer and you're also one
of the youngest graduates in oxford i'll get to
all that in a second it's a lot to touch upon
but let's we have to talk first about john
you played here in vikanze you played here
seven times and you won it three times in 1982
in 1990 and in 1991 so maybe my first question
to you is what memories do you have of playing
here in vikenzi i always enjoyed playing vikrante
you know it's always been a very friendly
tournament and of course if you have success on
the board it does create a favor of an impression
but even despite that even the years when i didn't
play so well i still had a good time and i always
looked forward to coming again the year after
and as you say i won three times once
once jointly in 1982 and twice outright
and yeah great times in those days well i
can i can only imagine and uh let's maybe
especially talk about the achievement
of winning it back to back which
only very few players have apologies about
that hopefully hopefully we'll be all right now
uh john my apologies to you as well and welcome
back once again grandmaster john none with us
john i was just uh saying you won the tournament
back to back which only very few players have
achieved in the history of the tournament
do you have any special memories of that
yes i mean it was uh certainly a great chess
festival and of course it was not only the
grand master tournament but there were lots
of other events as well for for masters and
for club players and i often met you know dutch
players there every year who come and play one
of the lower tournaments and it was always fun
to chat to the chess enthusiasts of all levels
and excited a huge amount of public
interest and of course it still does today
i think one of the things that strikes me about
you know this icons hundred tournament is the
large amount of public interest big reports in
newspapers now of course we have internet and
video which you're heavily involved in um but it's
it's not only the chess it's also the way it's
brought to a wide audience that struck me as being
a particular feature of this event yeah i think it
really you know if i can say throughout the years
always have been such a big festival as you say so
many locals getting involved coming by it's free
entry everyone can join in on the fun and see
these you know best players in the world from so
so close up this year unfortunately the event had
to be very different with only only the 14 masters
no spectators no amateurs no challenger groups
um have you been following the tournament
yes i've been following the tournament um
so it kind of mixed back some very interesting
games obviously karana's game yesterday was
fascinating um good positional game yesterday by
harry krishna i thought um so yeah always a crop
of interesting games and maybe also in previous
years there was always a big side event here i if
i recall correctly there was always a big chess
problem solving competition did you ever come
to vikanzi for that rather than for the main
event in recent years yes several years ago
i came for the uh study solving competition
which was held and always on the final weekend
and i think i won it twice um but i didn't play
you know it was after my kind of retirement as
it were well i still play a little bit even
today at the moment it's all online of course
um but when i retired from playing professionally
again i enjoyed watching the tournament and i
took part in the solving competition
actually how do you balance the many
interests that you have these days so you're
still into problem solving i know that you
are very passionate about astronomy you're a
prolific author you have what it so many jazz
books so how do you how do you balance all these
things well it makes for a busy life of course but
um yeah i think i'm probably more heavily involved
in problem solving right now than playing chess um
well age is a factor but um i'm currently
actually the british problem solving champion
oh wow something you can do even when you're
in your mid 60s whereas that over-the-board
chest becomes i think quite difficult once you
start to approach 50 although of course you know
players like vichy have continued to have an
active career for quite a long time and i just
have a last couple of questions for you before we
before we let you go uh one of the other things
you're also still active in as a writing chess
books do you have any new books uh in coming up
well i've just released a book called the chess
in-game exercise book which um you know is for so
we say good club players um it's setting selling
very well and it's a whole book of training
exercises for the end game um of course as the
author i'm definitely going to recommend it i'm
sure that would be very useful for a lot of our
views so go get your hands on it and john uh just
the last question for me i think one of the most
interesting things um about all your achievements
is you actually graduated um from oxford college
uh well at 15 at 15 years of age you were oxford's
youngest undergraduates it's kind of since
cardinal wolsey in 1520 so you know something
about uh what it is to be you know a child prodigy
and i i wanted to ask you on your thoughts about
ali zafiruja who these days you know he's the
the child prodigy i think of the chess world
so what are your thoughts on ali raza well he's
obviously an incredibly talented player i mean a
lot of success and you know a bright career ahead
of him but one thing i should say is that i was
considered a child prodigy and then the years
passed and then suddenly without any warning it
seemed i was the oldest player in the tournament
so it doesn't last forever enjoy it while you can
actually there's one last thing that's just
secure to me now i remember i'd forgotten about
this but i remember reading that magnus carlsen
actually said about you in an interview that the
reason you didn't become a world champion it's
because you were too smart for for your own good
and too many interests so what did you make of
magnus's assessment well he's a very polite man
john we'll end it we'll end it on that thank you
so very much for your time it was an absolute
pleasure uh having you and i hope we'll have you
back here in vaikanji on site in the coming years
sure thank you very much thank you have a nice
day and we'll be back with dania in just a second
and welcome back welcome back dania it's great
having you back but it was also so great having uh
john none on the show i mean such an accomplished
man but so nice so humble and it was a great
great to hear it from him but let's go back to
the games now a lot of action here in round four
indeed indeed there is and uh really i
mean he's just such a legend i mean so
multifaceted so many achievements from books
to puzzle solving genius astronomy photography
i mean a true renaissance man in in the best
possible way and that was that was awesome
and uh i think you conducted that great so
let's let's jump back into the games though
um any game that you'd like to start with a
particular fiona anything catching your eye
well let's i saw you hover for a second over
the magnus game do we have a couple more pieces
coming off the board there so after c4 jordan did
indeed so rookie one was one of the two moves that
um was one of the two moves that we had mentioned
just sort of improving the position magnus
responding in kind with the move rook a to e8 and
now jordan going a4 and basically what he's done
is he's waited for black to get off of the eight
file and now of course because he's got a rook on
a1 opening up the a file is kind of in his favor
um and and also that leads to more trades and
you know you heard and certainly wouldn't mind a
draw magnus does trade on e1 and magnus has just
taken on d3 so rapidly we see a lot of pieces
coming off the board what i think magnus wants
to do here is perhaps go queen to b3 and actually
try to go go after these pawns so this is no lag